I wrote 700 emails in 700 days. And in
this video, I'm going to tell you
exactly what happened. What's going on?
My name is Alan Drau. If you are new to
the channel, welcome. I'm glad you're
here. Let me give you the backstory. So,
about 2 and 1/2 years ago, I was
actually sending a weekly newsletter
called Sunday 6. And I did that for
about 12 months leading up to this
moment. This was typical to what
everybody had told me to do. Send a
weekly newsletter, drive social media
traffic to your weekly newsletter, sell
your products, blahy blahy blah. Well,
after 12 months of sending my weekly
newsletter called Sunday 6, I had gotten
a whopping 200 subscribers. That's not
good. And I just could not figure out
why nobody cared to read my newsletter.
In fact, not only was I not getting
sales, I was barely even getting replies
to my weekly newsletter. So after 12
months, I had hit a brick wall and I
knew that I needed some help. So I
reached out to my friend on Twitter
named Eddie Quan. Eddie Quan is a
creator in the space that I really loved
reading his emails and I wanted to
figure out how to grow my email list.
And I said, "Would you coach me? Would
you teach me how to grow my newsletter?"
Eddie said, "Bada bing, bada boom. I got
a new cohort coming up." And he said,
"Why don't you jump into my cohort? I'm
going to teach you in 3 days how to grow
your email list." So, I jump into
Eddie's cohort. I take notes. I watch
all his videos. I do the online
coaching. We get on a Zoom every single
night for three nights for two hours. He
grills me on my emails, my writing, my
techniques. But on day three, he says,
"I need you to change this up." I said,
"Sure, Eddie, whatever you want me to
do." He goes, "I want you to write a
daily email." I said, "Daily?" Brother,
they're not even reading the weeklies.
He said, "No, dude. I want you to pick a
topic you are fired up about, something
that you could be consistent on,
something you love, and I want you to
write an email every single day. I said,
"Starting when?" He said, "Tonight. I
want you to start tonight."
I said, "You want me to start sending
emails to my whopping 200 list starting
tonight? And you think that's going to
help me grow?" So, I did. I started
sending daily emails from that moment
two and a half years ago. And since
then, I've sent over 700
emails. And let me tell you, the result
of all of that work. Funny enough, the
result is actually the opposite of what
everybody else warned me would happen
when I started sending daily emails. I
had people in my Twitter DMs, for
whatever reason, start telling me, "You
are going to hate writing an email every
single day. You're going to burn
yourself out. You're going to burn your
list out. You're going to run out of
ideas. It's going to be very bad. And
you're gonna get so many unsubscribes
that your list is absolutely going to
tank. This is what everybody told me.
And I am here to tell you that the
opposite actually happened. Wow. That's
right. Ain't that crazy? Let me tell you
five things that actually happened when
I started writing a daily email over 2
years ago. The first thing that happened
is my email list exploded. Just like
Eddie said, and I didn't understand at
the time, but I understand now why.
Because when I started sending a daily
email, I actually started building a
deeper relationship with the people who
did really care about what I was talking
about. Now, the caveat to this is when I
swapped from my Sunday six to my daily
newsletter, I swapped from talking about
six things in the marketing world that I
really liked and I went specifically in
on copywriting. So, I niche changed and
I doubled down on how much I was talking
about the one thing that I really loved
in marketing, which was copyright. Not
only did I start sending seven times the
amount of emails people were used to, I
went deeper into a niche that would hit
an even smaller audience of people. But
what that did was it built a deeper
relationship with the copywriters on my
list and they started replying to my
emails and telling other copywriters
about my daily emails. They started
sharing them on Twitter, on Instagram.
People were tagging me on stuff. They
were sharing my ideas. They were
forwarding to them friends. The second
thing that happened with sending a daily
email for over two years is my status
and authority exploded in my niche. So
I'm in the copywriting niche. You're a
copywriter. You could be in any niche.
Health, fitness, gaming, whatever. I
write for copywriters. And in the
copywriting world, my status exploded
because of my daily emails. It was very
much like a snowball effect. I'd ended
up writing a bunch of emails. One of
them caught the attention of Ben Settle,
who I am an email player subscriber. He
shared about it in his email newsletter
and that caught a lot of other people's
attention, including one, Daniel
Thorell. Daniel Thrasell is on Ben's
list clearly. And then Daniel actually
hopped on my list because of the email
that Ben wrote. Me and Daniel ended up
collabing on some stuff. I joined his
list, bought his stuff that connected me
with Chris Orzacowski. I started going
back and forth with him, hired Chris as
my coach. That connected me with Kevin
Rogers and Copy Chief. I jumped in
there, started hanging out with them,
which led to another connection to
another connection to another connection
and I just started growing my status in
the copywriting world. For somebody who
was genuinely a nobody 2 and 1/2 years
ago in this copywriting space, I am
known by probably almost all of your
favorite copywriters. And all of that
stemmed from showing up every single day
and writing really good emails to my
email list. That's status. That's
authority. Which leads me to the third
thing that happened by writing 700
emails in 700 days. And that is my brand
became a business. Everybody wants a
personal brand online. They want a huge
audience, a huge YouTube account,
Instagram, Twitter, all this stuff.
Massive monetization dollars and all
this stuff. But very few people are
willing to put in the work or actually
know how to do the work. Or worse,
people grow this massive audience and
they don't know how to actually turn it
into a business. I know that because I'm
in a group with about 10 other
entrepreneurs who are also creators
online. And my email list and YouTube
and Twitter and all that stuff is about
onetenth the size of these other guys.
But I make 10 times more money with my
email list than they do. Because it just
so happens that if you send more emails,
you get to sell more stuff. And not in a
sleazy way. I never sell anything to my
list that I don't personally vouch for,
use, and believe it will change your
life. Which has also helped build my
trust over the last 2 years is that
people know if I drop a product, it's
going to be incredible. Hell yeah. So,
back to the simple math, seven emails a
week equals seven opportunities to sell
something as opposed to one email a
week. Imagine only having one
opportunity a week to sell people
something on your list. That's 52 sales
opportunities in the year. Well, I have
sales opportunities in the year, which
is the simplest way to 7x your sales. If
you want to know exactly how I sell in
every single email and still get people
to open my emails every single day, then
you need to hop on my email list,
allry.com.
And when you hop on my email list, you
will get a free gift, Copywriting
Catalyst, which is 63 cash cow
copywriting tips. It's like a micro
course that you can read each tip in 90
seconds or less, get something
incredibly valuable out of it, and apply
it immediately. The fourth thing that
happened by writing a daily email was I
turned my email list into the ultimate
practice platform. One of the most
questions that people ask me every day
is literally, "How do I practice
copywriting?" Well, having a daily email
list is the number one way to practice
copywriting, which is why I got so
freaking good in 2 and 1/2 years was
that I would read a copywriting book, a
sales letter, my email players,
Adventures in Copy Lane. I would read
something that would teach me better
copy, highlight a note, and say, "hm,
I'm going to try that tomorrow." And I
knew that the next day I would have an
opportunity to try a new copywriting
technique to sell something to be more
persuasive to tell better stories
because every day without fail I'm going
to write an email. Which leads me to the
number five thing that happened writing
700 emails in 700 days is I found my
writing style. If you go back and read
my emails from 2 and 1/2 years ago, they
really don't sound like I sound today.
Because when you first start writing a
daily email, you sound like the people
you read. You imitate your heroes uh far
too much. Which that's fine because in
the beginning that's like
apprenticeship. You are apprenticing
under writers that you love and you just
happen to sound and feel like them. So
for me in the beginning I sounded a lot
like Ben Settle, which isn't necessarily
my style. He's more edgy. He's more bold
where I'm more bombastic and optimistic.
But over time, I started incorporating
styles from like John Mark Homer, Seth
Goden to Daniel Thrasell, and Chris
Orzacowski. And now I have this mishmash
posh of a writing style that feels like
my own. And I never would have gotten
there had I not written an email every
single day and realized what I like,
what I'm good at, what I'm consistent
at, and just carve that voice. So with
that, I'm going to leave you with one
tip. If this video inspired you to be a
daily email copywriter, and that one tip
is write about something you genuinely
love. The hardest part about writing
daily is not the ideas. It's not the
burnout. It's not the people on your
list. It is, can I show up every day and
absolutely love what I talk about? Maybe
you love golf. Maybe you love watches.
Maybe you love sneakers. Maybe you love
swimming. It doesn't matter. Whatever
you love, start an email list around the
thing you love. Talk about it every day.
Tie it to a product that you could sell
and show up. If you do this for a year,
I guarantee that you will have high
status and high authority in the niche
that you want to have high status in.
And obviously, if you're watching this,
you're very likely a copywriter. If you
want daily inspiration and
accountability to show up every single
day, then I highly recommend jumping on
my email list, all along.com.
jump on there, get my daily emails, get
a great daily email copywriting tip,
read an incredible story that I write
for you every single day. I hope this
video was inspiring to you. And if it
was, make sure to like and subscribe to
the channel. That means a lot and it
tells me that you want more free videos
like this. In fact, just as a thank you,
remember you can click the description
below and get Copywriting Catalyst for
free. Literally click the link, put your
email in, it'll hit your inbox, and you
can start learning copywriting tips
today. That's it. That wraps us up. We
crushed it. I hope this inspired you.
I'm so sto so stoked. And I will catch
you on the next one. I'm writing my
daily email right now. Just made a video
about writing daily emails. Talking
about inception. I'm like writing a
daily email about writing a daily email.
How far does this go? All right.
Seriously, subscribe to the channel.
Like the video. Why are you still here
and you haven't done that? Unbelievable.
Smash it. Smash the like. Smash the
subscribe. Smash it harder than you
smash any.
Subscribe. Bam.
[Applause]